moments ago john roberts reporting from
administration official the president
the vice president met this evening in
the oval office
the two had a good conversation
discussing the week ahead and reflecting
on the last four years
of the administration's work and
accomplishments they reiterated that
those
who broke the law and stormed the
capitol last week do not represent the
america first
movement backed by 75 million americans
and pledged to continue
the work on behalf of the country for
the remainder of their term
that was one of the questions about
their communication and what that
relationship looks like
patched up jeff well i think it's
probably too early to say patched up but
certainly
uh critical and important that they met
i had spoken to one
former white house official last week
who speculated that the two men might
never speak again so
this is this is perhaps the process in
patching up that rift
what is interesting to me though also
about that statement that you just read
from a senior administration official is
it reads a little bit like a readout
that the white house would release when
the president meets with a foreign
leader
and the fact that they needed to release
a readout between the president and the
vice president
at all is certainly reflective of how
bad the breach was in the last few days
well sure i mean kimberly the president
was out on that speech before all of
that happened last
wednesday uh saying he was disappointed
he tweeted all these things about pence
and then
all the stories about him not reaching
out in the middle of the mayhem
what what about the status of
impeachment where it goes and the timing
here
as we have probably a little bit more
than 200 hours left of this
administration
well i think that's a crucial point
because it's not just
there isn't the will for this in the
senate you don't have the number of
people you need to convict
but you don't have the time uh it sounds
as though the house is going to bring
this up on wednesday
even if they did it all in a day that
would leave six
days for the senate to get through an
entire impeachment process
and that would be just to then deprive
the president of one day
in office and look i think one of the
most important things
senator manchin said there is this is
most hurting joe biden
we don't have any of his national
security staff
or nominees confirmed yet that's
unprecedented and the senate simply
doesn't have time to do both of these so
it would be better
if the vice president or the
president-elect came out and
told his party to stand down brit
in this same time we have the acting
homeland security secretary
stepping down saying it was warranted by
the actions of the past few days it's
going to be a bumpy ride
january 20th well he also said didn't he
bret that
because it had been the court had ruled
that he was not legally in office
because of the manner of his appointment
as acting
uh that was one of the reasons too but
look these people are leaving this
administration this administration is
ending
it's days away as you point out from
being completely gone
so um these steps are not surprising and
it illustrates how little is left of the
trumpet
trump administration and the trump
presidency so it
suggests to me at least how sort of
unnecessary
the act of impeaching would be although
you know a lot of people think you know
this guy did this stuff it was terrible
his insurrection and all the rest of it
but
but as has been amply pointed out here
this steps all over the moment in which
joe biden the healer and the new
president is intended to step forward
and convey his message of togetherness
and unity to the american people on the
you know on the day of his inauguration
and you know to get done the
cabinet appointments that he's hoping
swiftly to complete
as he starts his administration jeff you
know
there's this uh trip uh tomorrow to the
to the border
and it's in a town called alamo
that was planned beforehand but a lot of
people looking at this and saying what
will the final days of this
administration look like
there's a lot of stories about aids
trying to focus on the accomplishments
of the past
four years yes i've reported that too
that the the president's staff
are encouraging him to discuss and focus
on his legacy
uh the the last remaining days of
governing and to talk about his
accomplishments but in that same breath
i've spoken to white house officials who
say it's tone deaf to be trying to do
any of that
in the wake of what happened at the
capitol and so there is
i mean one white house official telling
me a few days ago that
nobody cares at all and that i think was
a reflection both on
some people at the white house and
people elsewhere in the country i don't
think that is true for everyone
uh certainly there are people here at
this white house who are deeply saddened
and and um really really really upset
about what happened on wednesday because
they feel uh not only because but at
least partially because they feel it's
overshadowing what they believe
should be a strong legacy from this
president yeah i think that's a common
refrain from trump supporters i've
talked to is sadness
panel thank you very much we'll cut